people of the internet retro wrecking
tour here I'm just a dad who loves games
and the stories they tell and today we
play Hogwarts Legacy dark arts battle
arena
no unforgivable curses and hard mode
Let's Do It
All Right wave one and let's do this go
ahead and hit you with an ancient magic
throw
I'm just gonna try and hit a lot of
stupefy because the Stupify that I have
does do extra damage well that was not
bad at all if that's how easy the
challenge is going to be this could be
over pretty quickly
all right plenty of these barrels
scattered around the area now we do
start seeing some attacks here that we
cannot carry
oh man look at that I mean Stupify is
just really doing well on these guys
right now hit that one with an ancient
magic attack and on to wave three this
may be a very very quick video ladies
and gentlemen we'll see now if you're
wondering why that little curse effect
pops up that is something that I have
applied to my Stupify so that it is
through the dark arts tree
I mean just this ancient magic throw
right now is proving absolutely
devastating okay I can definitely tell
an increase in difficulty we've got a
lot more enemies flying around now and
stupefy is not going to take down the
shields on some of these guys
so what we're gonna have to do instead
is we're gonna have to wait for an
ancient magic throw
or we're gonna have to wait till we have
a full ancient magic attack okay right
there see I messed up again I cannot
block that attack oh goodness yeah we
definitely need to heal all right it's
just this last guy and I just realized
we haven't used confringo at all just
yet
now the question is can I actually beat
this guy without using one of the
unforgivables yes we can because we just
unlocked an ancient magic so if we don't
have an ancient magic attack we could be
in big trouble and I'm also seeing that
it looks like the little objects around
the world that you can use Ancient magic
throw on I did not think that was gonna
hit me but okay we already do have
confringo back again they're both
getting pretty low
Dodge now get ready do it yes there we
go stupefy hit you a couple times with
that oh block you fire back with R1 how
about a confringo there we go got that
one out of the way okay so I'm just
gonna keep stockpiling ancient magic
right now
all right go ahead do that one yeah
boom boom boom Another confringo Dodge
out of the way yeah I don't want to use
it on him because we can take him out
pretty easily here so a little bit
difficult right there but we are all
ready to the final wave ladies and
gentlemen now you know what I think I
might just go ahead let's just start off
with an ancient magic right away on him
and you can see it instantly takes him
out
and then this time I'm gonna make sure I
keep an ancient magic attack around
just in case
we don't destroy now these shields of
course I don't need to worry about I can
just hit those with confringo no problem
there we go
enjoy suffering do you talking to me
buddy you talking to me if you time it
just right on these guys let's see if we
can get this one to do it here he's kind
of glitching through the wall right now
oh there he goes there he goes and of
course right when I start to roll that's
when oh there we go we can hit it on
that guy right there and you can just
see instant takedown on him let's hit
you with a confringo actually you know
what we're gonna save for you my friend
we are going to save that ancient magic
attack
see whenever I made my spell ranking
video
some people thought I was crazy for
putting protego and stupefy too high so
you know what I just have to show them
right here
you can almost do this entire dark arts
Arena
whoops can't do it right there though
you can almost do this whole entire
Arena
you know what let's just go ahead and
you know what hit him with the ancient
Magic
is that it is that it ladies and
gentlemen we've gotta up the stakes
ladies and gentlemen we have to do the
same challenge again but this time we
are not allowed to use any wig and well
potions whatsoever no wig and well
potions at all which means we have to be
really careful make sure we hit all
these protegos when we can as I've
already missed a couple here and you
know one other thing I'm trying to do
this time is I'm really gonna try to
make sure that I leave some of these
objects around I'm telling you man
Stupify or potato Stupify It Is Just
Deadly right now and again I'm also
gonna
that was terrible okay we got a lot
going on right now I'll go ahead and use
a couple of the objects here
all right let's go ahead and use that
one on you
get rid of that Shield
keep forgetting I can totally use
confringo though okay I can't do
anything with you right now except for
this
let's go ahead and get a potato and
Stupify on you
oh my goodness man look at the basic
shot all right troll time
one two oh he did he he changed up the
attack pattern right there
that is my favorite thing right there I
love that man
oh and he goes with another one
and right beside him decided to do it
too
it just feels so great man to do that in
in this game when enemies oh
that was a lot of damage okay we can run
around and grab these though
even though we cannot use Wicked welds
cannot use Wicked welds cannot use
Wicked welds how are we still alive
I do not understand how we're still
alive ladies and Gentlemen let's go
ahead and hit you with an ancient Magic
get rid of you
we cannot play around at all with this
troll right here
Dodge Dodge
go for it now yes there it is stupefy
the basic attack ladies and gentlemen
it is so ridiculously powerful
Dodge Dodge oh man he tried to grab me
do you see that
I don't know what he was about to do
and we've got an R1 right there let's go
let's go let's go nice okay completing
that wave we should have an opportunity
here to heal yeah there it goes the
automatic healing kicks in but it did
not heal very much did it all right
here's what we need to do we need to
lock onto the troll
no not you
okay that's fine you know what we have
so many ancient magic attacks kind of
banked
oh this is bad I'm just gonna I'm just
gonna start ancient Magic on everybody
here okay the troll right there that's
who I want to Target with it instantly
get rid of him
dude it's it's so many habits right now
I'm wanting to press heels so bad okay
we've kind of thinned out the crowd a
little bit
no not on you
oh let's do this right here hit you with
a confringo
oh no I didn't see that one okay let's
take out these just kind of smaller
enemies around the side
that was close man all right ancient
Magic on you
hit you with a confringo can't
take on that
can do R1 right there though
oh man
I don't like this
yes
okay we've still got more though come on
go ahead do it
all right how about you you the last one
you gonna do it you gonna attack
let's go you've ladies and gentlemen we
just completed the challenge no wig and
weld potions no unforgivable curses dark
arts battle arena complete let me know
in the comments below what other
challenges you'd like to see me try as
always thank you all so much for
watching I'll talk to you again soon